a relationship between scholarship and
really new scholarship that are that
people are doing that I feel excited by
and then instead of communicating both
stories that are big stories you never
have a student coming who doesn't know
Shakespeare right so big stories but not
sort of re only revivifying those big
stories not simply resisting them right
been really thinking about that balance
between you know what people are
thinking and writing what people have
thought and read in the past and then
the kind of big stories that students
come in especially in a school that has
a core curriculum big stories that they
have like often my Shakespeare class we
begin with student saying which do you
think is the greatest of Shakespeare's
tragedies right and you know it's not
exactly my approach and so you know you
hope by the end the students are asking
different kinds of questions like huh so
certain plays repulsions lifetime in
certain plays weren't you know why was
he running in certain genres at a
particular moment right what did it mean
that they were boy players on the stage
you know what did it mean that
Shakespeare's a shareholder and all of
those insights come from scholarship
right and they have changed like I think
most people don't think Shakespeare now
is a solitary genius they understood
that you as a shareholder and so they
come from scholarly insights that have
had a kind of trickle down effect right
and partly one of the ways of thinking
about teaching is that right is is not
trickle down like I'm going to give you
a dumbed down version of the most
recent scholarship but you know like I
said we vivifying extant interests with
sort of new knowledge and new approaches
in my experience is when you're excited
about it yeah students are going to be
excited about it so even if you're
talking about common placing in Hamlet
right students are going to get excited
about it because they can see or they
can experience your own sort of feeling
around how does this if it all changed
some of the ways that we've been talking
about Hamill today